Hello, I'm Ed Sheeran
and I'm an English
singer-songwriter
auditioning to be
in the British Money Heist.
Yes, welcome. Tell us a
little bit about yourself.
So, I'm a singer and...
I've been a liar,
I've been a thief.
Sorry, what was that?
Don't worry.
I was just
thinking out loud.
I'm here to audition
for Glasgow
'cause I hear he's,
you know,
the British version
of Berlin.
And I thought
it would be a good fit.
Right, perfect.
Well, first off,
and I don't want to step
on your toes here,
but I thought we could
change the character's name
from Glasgow to Ipswich.
Just 'cause it's a little
bit more personal to me,
you know, and
if I'm gonna do the role...
Alright, Ed Sheeran
as Ipswich.
Take one.
Do you know what five
divorces mean?
It's five times
I've been in love.
Let the matriarchy begin.
Yeah, I know
that's Nairobi,
I just wanted to say that.
Este es un momento
maravilloso.
Okay, another one.
This is a wonderful moment.
So I know Pedro Alonso
is an amazing singer
and I love that scene
at the wedding
but for the UK version,
I thought
I could sing this one...
Baby, I'm
dancing in the dark
with you between my arms.
Barefoot on the grass,
listening to our
favourite song...
-What do you think?
-What else can you show us?
My bad habits lead to big
heists stealing some gold.
Conversations with my
brother singing Bella Ciao.
Swearing this will be the
last, but it probably won't.
I got nothin' left to lose,
or use, or do.
I know I've lived my life
like a son of a bitch
but I feel like dying
with dignity.
I'd also love to audition
for the Professor.
Welcome.
We are gonna rob
Buckingham Palace.
Let me tell you how.
Do you know
what Aikido means?
Inspector?
What are you wearing?
Inspector.
So, what do you think?
Well, yeah,
I loved it but...
Really, there's someone
else who has the last word
on all the auditions
for the show.
-Hello Ed.
-Hey.
What are you wearing?
Just kidding.
Hey, I liked your take
on the Professor.
You almost got
the glasses trick right.
Personally I think
I see you more
as one of the members
of la banda.
-Ipswich, right?
-Yes.
Hey, listen I really like
your Buckingham Palace idea.
So, I have business
proposal.
How does 2.4 billion Pounds
sound to you?
Tell me more.
So, I've got a suggestion
for the UK version
for a name change.
If you're up for it.
"Quid Game."